I see water when I go to the pond.
I can see land all around the water.
I see cattails when I go to the pond.
They are very tall.
I see lily pads when I go to the pond.
They are very round.
I see frogs when I go to the pond.
They sit on the lily pads.
I see turtles when I go to the pond.
They sit on a log.
I see ducks when I go to the pond.
They swim on the water.
I see fish when I go to the pond.
They swim in the water.
I see many things when I go to the pond.
The pond is a busy place.
What do you see when you go to the pond?
I can see a turtle. It sits on a log.
What else do you see when you go to the pond?
I can see frogs, too. They sit on the lily pads.
And you can see a duck. It swims on the water.
Right! I also see fish swimming in the water!